Franky Zapata arrived at this beach near
Calais hoping to make aviation history
normally super-confident he looked
nervous about the challenge ahead the 40
year old inventor knew the biggest
problem would be finding the ship
mid-channel
where he would have to refuel because
his kerosene powered device can only fly
for 10 minutes after much discussion and
preparation it was time for liftoff 26
miles of open sea stood between him and
history the launch itself went as
planned with hundreds of onlookers
coming out to see him off saboteur shot
to fame in France after his exploits at
the Bastille Day celebrations in Paris
on July the 14th the whole country has
got behind his invention but within
minutes of the launch it was clear that
something had gone badly wrong Frankie's
wife Kristin hugged their son Max as
news came through that he crashed into
the channel the refuelling stop had
proved to be his undoing these things
can happen and you can't foresee them he
travelled more kilometres than planned
he flew faster so there were good things
too the French government has given him
and million pounds of a grant to further
develop his fly board and he feels these
are early days for this device what
Frankie's teams say like all great
inventors he will learn from this and
come back even stronger yes it's a
setback but he wants to try again
exactly a hundred and ten years ago
Louie blury of blew off from northern
France to England making the first solo
flight across the channel Franky Zapata
is adamant he too can enter aviation
history but for now it's back to the
drawing board in the Brady Sky News in
sangat northern France